what did i walk in on what is this yummy
20 bucks
[Music]
guys guys real quick before you watch
this vlog i need you to go to corridor
digital watch our latest video we just
put it out it was a traumatic experience
you guys do not want to use instagram in
the bathroom anymore go click the link
in the description to find out why
you might remember from a few videos
back where sam made a very very obvious
debt with me for twenty dollars sam just
bet me he wouldn't say the word me ma
tomorrow you hear this voice it's not
gonna say those words again he's gonna
say it before 10 am before 10 am he says
i'm not going to say the word well guess
what he said it before 9 00 a.m start
with me moss
[Music]
brought it up with him and he hasn't
said anything he's been avoiding the
question
sam dude we got to talk about this debt
you owe me you said me
i ain't paying no debt till you do your
push-ups
but that has nothing to do with what is
money but something that's not real i
mean how is money any anymore don't try
to attack your way out how push-ups any
more real what is money listen i owe the
audience push-ups okay that's fine take
that let's set it aside that has nothing
to do with our debt you owe me 20 bucks
i don't have any cash on me would you
take an iou you know i've lost track of
how long it's been
this one i'm just going to let it blow
over see
some problems you don't want to handle
just by yourself sometimes you need
backup that's what i got right here
what's up
son what up son
[Music]
what's going on with the sam situation
well my friend we got a problem and i
think together we can solve it okay i
brought this jacket just in case i feel
like it looks cool there you go is it
going to stay there he was clamped 10
from the same the same bet you could
probably pick up half a cleanse and half
of mine you could probably make out of
here with 15 bucks right now
right now jake's a man who pays his
debts
exactly
there was no way that i was going to do
16 000 push-ups by the end of the year
there's just no possible way that's like
that's kind of doable though
maybe for you
no look at you why do you think i called
you dude because you probably can do 16
000 push-ups that's why i need your help
come on let's go let's do this do you
know how many push-ups that is it's not
like spending 16 000 you do
you do a thousand a week
you have it done what
a thousand a week thousand a week you
know how torn up your arms would be if
you did 320 push-ups a day dude you'd be
looking like marcus phoenix anyway son
this isn't why we're here okay
i need you to be tough for this okay
okay
you're gonna do the talking right yeah
okay
what's going on in here that's right sam
sam oh my god
i thought you were gonna kill me i mean
it's not too late for that but listen my
friend jake right here he says you owe
him quite a bit amount of money how much
money do you owe to him
samuel man you're holding me you're
hurting me you're hurting my shoulder
you're hurting my shoulder are you going
to pay us
first of all i want you to tell jake
here that you're sorry can you look at
him and tell him you're sorry i'm not
going to pay you
that's all right i'll pay you i'll pay
you i'll pay you i'll use venmo i'll
i'll do it hold on no we didn't talk
about that i'll use that i see him i
don't have the money on me but i have
another solution what other solution
trial buy combat we're gonna fight over
this we're gonna fight over it right now
yeah let's just kill him right now all
right all right try light combat
obviously we know who my champion's
gonna be right oh we've brought your son
driver that's me son
your champion's gonna be i'm gonna pick
her up
jake
welcome to real life rock'em stockholm
robots where a human controls another
human who fights as their champion robot
here's how this works you give your
teammate
you put a broomstick in the handle then
basically you can now you can go totally
limp go totally limp
are you totally lit
it's like piloting a mac or like a
specific rim or you're like
the way that this is gonna work is
there'll be two players one blue one red
in the center of the chest
we have the hype button the height
button is the equivalent of the head
popping off of the robot it's the
objective of the one side just like in
rock and soccer to punch
and to eliminate the other side i'm
picking christian as my technical combat
champion to stand in lieu of me since
i'm going to be fighting sam will be
controlling me
if i lose i win if if if brett wins i
lose what sam's cleared of his debt i
what is go i what did i walk in on this
what is this what are you doing rule
twist of fate right i chose jake as my
robot champion so now jake has he's got
a moral conundrum going on we have the
weirdest jobs
remember i'm out to lose this you have
to control my hands to try to win you're
fighting uphill battles
the controls are a little janky you
better kick my ass fred all right so
we're going to be going first to five
points you better mess me up son i'm
going in you better mess me up
you better mess me up
come on brad
come on brad
[Applause]
round one point two brett round two
i'm doing sound design for dick pic it's
fun but it's very tedious it's a long
process i'm not a sound designer so i'm
just doing my best i think the longest
part is finding good sounds yeah that's
probably the most time consuming part
everything else is fun like piecing it
together it is very important that i
focus today and avoid as many
distractions as possible so hopefully
it's going to be quiet in the office
today
dude come on you know it's satisfying
we're firing on all cylinders today guys
we got we got jared over here
for this fortnight video
sorry
yeah yeah here i got you right here
thank you
we got nails firing off we got people
sledgehammers up here gonna tear that
thing down and i'm trying to do sound
design luckily i have these sennheisers
pxc 550s they're taking care of all that
ambient noise for me but um if i were to
be using anything else it'd be trouble
tell me if this distracts you okay
here we gather like a bunch of dudes we
can definitely make some more white
noise for you i mean i i think i have
enough white noise like in this video
already like between the chainsaws and
the loud cars and whatnot uh-huh so i'll
probably be good on that cool good luck
thanks
so far off to a good start
round three it's hard yeah that's three
round three
nice
it's really hard when the robot has the
natural instinct to defend itself but i
get it self preservation
i'm trying to do double
good good job brent
good job
[Applause]
begin
you got smoked
you got smoke son
my boys are killing you
i'm about to lose everything
oh
oh
we need more velcro why'd it get wet
because you poured water on them
oh yeah
all right
get up
three what
i knew i shouldn't have chosen my
greatest enemy as my champion
i'm gonna pop you up in like a pinatas
huh
i'm gonna pop you in my head
three
all right the score is three to two now
i want you to dig deep on this one who
want you to think about grandma
hey what you think about grandma think
about all the things she done taught you
think about how many times she said me
mom trade me
i heard that what you got me
i heard that horn
you hit jake first i saw your fist hit
and then a moment later i heard your
height button
it's now four to two no one's ever come
back from those odds
all right come on one more hit son
one more hit want me to hit you scores
four to two
come on brad
stop trying to hit me and hit me
don't leave me open
sam
you paid me that money sam
you lost that game for me you paid me
that money i was gonna win and then you
lost it for me
you lost son
truly a robot yeah control your robot
christian you owe me that money sam
you ended up paying me 20 dollars do you
want venmo
you want to venmo all right then you
gotta let me punch you in the face no
let me i'll go i'll find an atm
i want to get a punch i'm expecting my
money by the end of the day all right
before you go on vacation all right i'm
going to give the money
hey sam
hey nick how's it going my brand new
avatar that jake recommended to me it's
not working very well
i'm trying to use the joystick okay um
i told you how incredible gage allen is
have i told you how magnificent phillip
oxford is if i told you how devious and
dastardly
the
[Music]
another friend of
[Music]
but on the internet
hey
[Music]
if you head over to our patreon page
right now
all right we're just gonna stay there
for now okay
quick
guys i think the last one alive in the
studio also do you have a couple days
left to get this sweet shirt corridor
digital.com go there buy the shirt and
then send for help
clerydigital.com no humans in here get
out here save yourself